that's true but i'll allow it because it
does sound fun and this trial is for fun
and i just didn't know what else to do i
didn't know what to say i didn't know
how to react lance bass and saturday
night live face backlash following
parodies of johnny depp and amber
heard's court battle
i thought this is how i die
he's going to kill me now
in depth's ongoing defamation lawsuit he
and heard have both described instances
of alleged abuse against each other
grabbed me by the hair
swung me around
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
now weeks into the case snl decides to
make light of the trial with cast member
kyle mooney portraying dead mr depp are
you finding this trial amusing
a little
yes
so am i
you're bad captain jack
the sketch even makes reference to the
shocking video recordings aired in court
i'd like to see more of this video
why
because it's funny
days later the instinct star shares this
post to tic toc i lose my balance
at this point we're sitting next to each
other on the edge of the couch i was on
the edge of the couch
the audio lance's lip dubbing
that's a snippet from heard's testimony
which has become a viral trend on the
platform i was just sitting there on
this on on this
carpet looking at the dirty carpet i was
just sitting there on this on on this
carpet looking at the dirty carpet
wondering how i wound up on this carpet
and why i was
never why i never noticed that the
carpet was so filthy before and i just
didn't know what else to do i didn't
know what to say i didn't know how to
react these parodies are getting some
mixed feedback to say the least
amid several domestic abuse claims
critics are saying any attempt to poke
fun at the trial is in bad taste
well on one hand i've never seen a case
quite like this before as legal expert
jessie weber tells et the media
attention adds a new layer to the
already complex legal battle the
celebrity factor here particularly the
fan base for johnny depp
is so unique so it's going to be kind of
tough to judge other abuse cases that
have happened or might happen based on
this one but having said that i am
concerned at how cavaliers society has
been at dismissing amber herd's
allegations it's disturbing and yes it's
going to give maybe people in the future
pause before they come forward with
allegations against an a-list celebrity
i mean ironically this was the very
thing that amber heard warned about in
her washington post article the article
that johnny depp is suing about that she
came forward and society and culture
went against her
[Music]